everyone i know remembers the teachers
their attributes their qualities the
characteristics
the names the nicknames the mannerisms
and their influence
the teacher who shows you how to read
and write the teacher who introduces you
to the literature history
and culture of your country the teacher
who encourages you to bridge the gap
between who you are and what you have it
in yourself to become
teachers change lives no one more so
than ranchers in desales who today wins
the 2020 global teacher prize
ranjit has never stopped believing in
the power of education
working from a dilapidated classroom he
personally rewrote his students
textbooks
so they could understand them in their
own language and he worked
extraordinarily hard to ensure that
girls as well as boys attended classes
and as a result child marriage for young
teenage girls
has fallen dramatically grandeur
represents teaching
at its best a vacation a profession
whose skills and traditions
are handed down to us from generation to
generation
a sacred trust and it is our
responsibility to stand by the teaching
profession
as they prepare and nurture the next
generation
but today education is in crisis over
the last year nine and ten of all
learners
had their education disrupted by
lockdowns the covert 19 pandemic has cut
the link between the teacher and the
classroom
as budgets are hit worldwide there's a
significant risk that instead of
recognizing that we must invest to build
back better
governments will make short-term savings
at the expense of much-needed long-term
investment
in technology and most of all in
teachers themselves
nelson mandela said that promises to
children are sacred
they cannot and must not be broken our
promise that in our generation
every childhood of the chance of
schooling is being betrayed by cuts in
the education budgets
amounting to over 100 billion dollars
worldwide
instead of developing some of the
talents of some of our children in some
of the world's countries
we have a duty to develop all the
talents of all of our children
in all the countries of the world that's
why today i'm
urging the international community to
act now to save our future to protect
education budgets
to invest in teachers teachers need our
support
now more than ever by backing incredible
teachers like ranjit we can find a way
through
and defeat this crisis